past few weeks in the wake of the
killing of George Floyd we have seen a
bunch of stuff happening and some of the
things that we've seen has been the
destruction of statues the renaming of
schools they desire to destroy certain
aspects of American culture especially
so I'm going to look at that what it
means to destroy statues what it means
to do that the answer I give you might
not be the one that you want but
nonetheless hopefully will help you
understand this pattern and why it is
that people would engage in such
behavior
[Music]
this is Jonathan pezzo welcome to the
symbolic world
[Music]
one of the things we've seen in the past
few weeks has been the massive attack on
monuments now the beginning of these
attacks were of course on Confederate
statues on different characters which
represent the south and for some people
who were associated with the slavery in
the south
but that of course it went much further
than that
we saw a statue of Thomas Jefferson
being destroyed there was also a statue
of Ulysses Grant being destroyed who is
strangely is the general who actually
defeated the South in the Civil War now
there was even a statue of Abraham
Lincoln which was defaced in Europe and
there is a threat on a statue of Abraham
Lincoln who is the very person who
liberated the slaves in America so the
question is what is happening why are
people doing this
and the first thing I have to tell you
and like I said some people might not
like this is that destroying statues in
itself is not a bad thing people
everybody destroys statues every culture
destroy statues there is an inevitable
aspect to any civilization that it will
tend to diminish that which was there
before Christians did the exact same
thing when Christians Christianized the
Roman Empire one of the aspects of what
they did was to destroy or to remove at
least in public view the statues of the
ancient gods
the statues which were there in which
the Emperor's were being worshipped
these types of statues were
progressively removed from the public
sphere the same thing happened as
Islamic you know Islamic culture took
over a took over certain regions one of
the things they did was to remove the
statues of the pagan gods to remove even
the the images of the Christian saints
as they were taking over that area and
like I said I know this is difficult for
some people to understand but everybody
does that let's say that
you buy a house and you and your family
you're going to move into this new house
that you bought and this house belong to
a family that was there before you until
you buy the house you go in and you
notice that in the house for some reason
the people who were there before they
left pictures of themselves hanging on
the wall now you want that house to be
your house and so what you will do is
you're going to remove those pictures
because those pictures are now residues
of a former world they're residues of a
former identity which don't connect to
your identity and so in order to found
your identity you will have to clean up
you're going to have to remove markers
of the former identity which are too
strong which will clash which will cause
confusion in terms of your current
identity and so just as you do that in
your own house in the same manner any
new civilization will do the same and
I'm not trying to defend anything I'm
just describing the way it happens if a
group takes over another group one of
the things they're gonna want to do is
to remove markers that remind them that
this space in which they are used to
belong to somebody else and so the
removing of statues will happen
inevitably at the transition or the
removing of images will happen
necessarily at the transition between
two worlds when one world is changing
into another one of the things that's
going to happen is a type of iconoclasm
the destruction of the memory of the
ancient world and so the reason why I
say that is first of all for people to
understand that in itself this act is
one which is inevitable it's going to
happen but I also want you to understand
what it means when people start to
destroy
images start to destroy symbols of of an
identity it's because they want to
dismantle that identity because they
want to destroy that which was there
before and one of the things that
happens especially when you you come to
the end of something when you come to
the end of an identity and you start a
new one is that what you perceive of the
old identity is usually the negative
aspects of it and so you could say it
this way when you found something when
you found a new identity one of the
things that is necessary to do is like
you see in the Old Testament in the
story of Noah you have this story where
Noah is now the new father of the new
world Noah is about to start a new world
and in that moment there is a scandal
Noah gets drunk passes out naked in his
tent and one of his sons sees that and
mocks his father for this this this
event his other sons walk backwards and
cover the nakedness of his father and so
in order to found any identity which
holds together one of the things we need
to do is to walk backwards and cover the
nakedness of our origin of course
there's a limit to how much you can
cover but you you necessarily have to do
that think about it in terms of a family
now every family has certain aspects of
it which are not pretty certain aspects
of it which are not great you know you
know as a father I have my faults I have
my I have the things which are which I'm
not doing properly you know my wife as a
mother has things that she's doing well
other things that she's not doing well
but the the reality is that in order to
preserve the unity of the family one of
the things that has to happen constantly
is to
to a certain extent we need to walk
backwards and cover the nakedness of our
of our parents and because if we don't
if we expose constantly the nakedness of
our parents what's going to happen is
the family is going to break apart and
sometimes it should break apart if the
scandal is too great if the if the the
father abuses his children or you know
some horrible thing that that happened
then maybe that is too great and you
can't cover it and you shouldn't cover
it but they are everybody has their
fault you know everybody has their
little thing which which doesn't make
which shows that they're not perfect but
if you constantly expose that especially
if you expose it to the outside you're
exposing your weakness and your family
will will break apart if you do that and
so that is something which you
necessarily have to do in order to
preserve any country any any identity
your family your your group like if you
have a sports team and in your sports
team there are certain bad habits or
certain things that the way that the
players play you have to be careful not
to expose the weakness of your team too
much because you if you if you're
constantly talking about your star
player and his weaknesses and you expose
them then that will be used by your
enemy as a way to take over your team to
beat your team and so you have to cover
the nakedness of your own to a certain
extent like I said there's a limit at
which it's impossible or you should do
it because if the damage of covering the
nakedness like a case of abuse or
whatever then it's bad and you can see
that people have done that some people
have covered the sins too much you have
the stories of coaches of priests of
using children and and in order to
preserve the team people realize that if
we expose them at the time then it will
destroy the thing we care about and so
they actually preserve the scandal now
you can imagine there's a hierarchy of
that there are little things that go
wrong that you don't want to expose and
then there's a there's a point where you
you have to expose it if it gets too big
but you know that's difficult to know
when that's the case when you should do
one or you should do the other but one
of the things that will happen
inevitably is that shame that secret
that you hid is going to stay there in
the thing it's going to be the fatal
flaw of your identity the thing that
will in the end be exposed there's a
reason why Christ talks about how in the
end all that is hidden will be exposed
he's not just saying that in the terms
of a moral statement he's saying it
because it is the very process by which
an identity unfolds at first the the
fault of the of the identity or the
story of the character will be hidden
and as the story plays out and in the
end those things which were hidden at
the beginning will become the undoing of
the identity and so if you want to
understand what is happening now that is
what is happening that the origins of
that which was implicit in the origins
of America is playing out that is the
sins of the beginning are playing out
now the thing is that you can't avoid
those I'm not saying that two virtue
signal I'm not saying that to criticize
those leaders or to or to criticize what
was there I mean everybody has all
countries all stories all nations have
darkness in their origin that's because
we are broken and that's because we
human beings have a brokenness to them
you can't avoid it now in the founding
of America right imagine a nation that
was founded on the the idea of kingship
and hierarchy and strength and and all
of that and power and that was the main
core value of of the king and the king
you know this hereditary hereditary
kingship and he's the most powerful now
there are positive aspects to that but
they're often scandals and abuse is
hidden in that pattern and then
ultimately what will often happen is
that King will be undone by the very
dark aspects of kingship will be will be
taken by a coup from from his brother or
his cousin or someone else who's in line
to be king and they will use the dark
aspects of kingship in order to then
take it over now this is what is
happening in America as well one of the
things that America was founded on was
the notion of equality freedom freedom
and equality are the basis of the
American system and so in the very
founding of the United States was hidden
a sin there was a sin hidden in the the
we the people of the United States of
America in that very those very first
sentences the notion that we are that we
are born free that we are equal and that
these truths are seen as self-evident
that was hiding a sin because and it is
that which is being exposed now that is
that which which we are seeing is that
the very principle of equality and
freedom is now turning against those who
declared it Christ talks about how the
talks about how the measure by which you
judge others is the measure which will
be used to judge you and that is what
we're seeing happening right now and
like I said I don't want to defend it
because you have to understand that what
is at stake right now as you watch
statues of the founders of America and
the characters which mark American
history and European history what you're
seeing is an attack upon the very
identity of what you are you are
witnessing a revolutionary action that
is what you're witnessing and that's
important to understand that what is
happening is the dismantling of the
story and the identity
America now like I said the reason why
it's working is because the manner in
which that dismantling is being done is
through the very mechanisms of its
identity by exposing the nakedness of
the fathers by showing how they didn't
live up to their own standards how in
their very declaration of freedom and
equality they were enacting something
different and and the very the very
values by which they founded their
country is now coming back to devour
them and so I hopefully that will be
helpful and like I said I don't want to
I don't particularly like watching
iconic class I'm Emma I'm an icon Carver
I don't like watching iconic class take
down statues I don't particularly want
to see the Western world be dismantled
and and so hopefully what I'm giving to
you is at least a key and understanding
why it's happening how it's happening
and but I to be I have to be honest with
you at this point I don't have a
solution to offer to you I can only
point and help you understand how it's
happening and why it's happening but you
also have to understand as this ends
that one of the difficulties in what's
going on right now is for example when
Christianity took over the pagan world
there was a clear vision of what they
wanted to to bring about there was not
just a negative it wasn't just about
tearing down but there was a plan on
what of what they wanted to replace it
with if you move into a new house and
you take down the pictures of your take
down the pictures of the people who are
there before you do that with the
purpose of putting up your own pictures
at some point now it is not clear what
is supposed to replace this the identity
of the United States right now it is not
clear and what what appears to be
shaping itself on the horizon looks much
scarier than the the very real sins of
the
united states founders looks a lot
scarier than that and so I'm not
cheering I'm not cheering for the the
dissolution of the of the Western story
even though I disagree with some aspects
of it I'm definitely not cheering for
its dissolution and it's also important
to understand that once the once the
wheel of and once the wheel of
revolution is started it's very
difficult to stop because some of the
founders of the of those who are now the
woke culture some of those also have
very very deep sins in their story as
well and and those will inevitably be
exposed as well you know there are
reasons why there has never been a movie
made about MLK it's because he also has
for all the great things that he did
there are deep they're dark aspects to
his store in dark sins that he's hiding
for all the love people have of John of
JFK there's a reason why no one has
really made a movie about his life
either because his story is very dark as
well we have to be careful if we start
exposing the nakedness of our fathers
there there's very little stopping it
catching up we talked about how the
revolution eats itself and that's very
possible that we're gonna see that
happen happening at a faster and faster
rate and so sorry to be such a bummer
everybody but right that I guess that's
what's happening I still have the video
game movie on the interpretation of
Mario Brothers in the works for some
reason it's difficult to focus on that I
imagine you can see why but I'll get to
it of course and so it was great to talk
to everybody and I'll see you very soon
I hope enjoyed this interpretation of
the destruction of statues since I
recorded this it has been brought to my
attention that the activist Shawn King
has called for the destruction of all
Christian art which represents Christ
and his mother and his disciples as
being Westerners and so this story is
not over it's going to ramp up until the
destruction of all the roots of Western
culture it seems that that's the case
and that's what people are hoping for
and so if you enjoy what I'm doing
please consider supporting me as I deal
with these more controversial subjects
of course I'm going to be putting myself
on the bad side of YouTube I've already
seen that the algorithm is not favorable
to what I'm doing and so I really need
people to share the videos you know
share these ideas with your friends if
you agree with them and also consider
supporting me you can go to my website
the symbolic worldcom flash support
there you will also find on my website a
blog and a lot of resources related to
all this discussion on symbolism and so
thanks everybody and I will talk to you
very soon